die vorlesung diktatur revolution
ausnahmezustand überdies kontinuität in
der politischen philosophie und ich bin
eigentlich im hörsaal aber sonst kaum
jemand
es ist denkbar liebe zuhörer dass
zumindest einige von ihnen auch in den
usa kommen könnte denn anders mal dass
wir für mich auch nicht unangenehm weil
es etwas bezahlt ist jetzt vor einem
leeren raum zu sprechen aber ich werde
so weit geht mir vorstelle dass sie da
sind und ich mit ihnen rede
ok also das ist jetzt das thema das ist
normale vorlesungen sie kriegen auch die
punkte und alles wenn sie
prüfungsleistungen ablegen wollen
wichtig ist dass ein begleit tutorium
fest
auch arrangiert ist von philipp kochheim
dem sie auch übers über die das
vorlesungsverzeichnis kontaktieren
können oder einsehen können
und er ist auch mit für den inhalt
ein bisschen verantwortlich ok also
jetzt ganz kurz zu den materien da steht
nicht besonders viel drin in der
ankündigung
es tut mir leid ist halt so benjamin
walter benjamin und karl schmidt werden
die themen sein womit wir beginnen das
sind die materialien in meine
das ist ihr philosophie keine
ideengeschichte insofern geht es um
argumente nicht um persönlichkeiten aber
benjamin und karl schmidt sind bekannte
denker aus dem zwanzigsten jahrhundert
mit denen sie möglicherweise schon
vertraut sind
das ist also der erste anknüpfungspunkt
darüber hinaus geht es um im
wesentlichen zwei strömungen die eine
strömung die man eben mit dem gedanken
der diskonter diskontinuität verknüpfen
kann sind ja zb die revolutionäre auch
theologische denke das ist auch das wäre
beispielsweise dann marx und lenin ganz
wichtig für carl schmitt und auch für
walter benjamin und hinter ihm dann marx
dann auch den englischen philosophen
thomas hobbes das ist quasi die
diskontinuität politische theorie auf
dem hintergrund von größeren
gesellschaftlichen verwerfungen zb die
theologisch mit der diskontinuität
verbindet man denker wie also zb ein
bisschen walter benjamin wenn man seine
theologischen inhalte berücksichtigt
aber auch gerade in der
in der neuzeit kirkegaard sören
kierkegaard und dann im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert den französischen
philosophen also auch dort wird sehr
stark thematisiert die möglichkeit dass
sein dies kontinuierlich zu denken also
nicht nur politisch sondern auch
metaphysisch das ist die eine seite auf
der anderen seite ist ist das was karl
schmidt und andere gerade als gegner der
eigenen position hervorheben
das sind manchmal die liberalen oder die
bürgerlichen oder die individualisten je
nachdem aus welcher ecke man kommt und
das ist dann also standardmäßig mit der
liberalen tradition knüpft während das
jetzt innerhalb der politischen
philosophie der schotte hatte smith und
der ire edmund burke beide arten das
jahrhundert und das sind zwei ganz
wichtige denker für die vorstellung dass
das es auch in der politik keine
radikale diskontinuität gibt ja also der
ausgangspunkt ist ist diese vorstellung
man kann den lauf der dinge unterbrechen
und neu beginnen
und das ist etwas was eigentlich sehr
attraktiv ist dass man relativ oft auch
jetzt in der gegenwart hört es hat dann
zunächst mal mit rechts oder links nicht
allzu viel zu tun zum beispiel der wohl
prominenteste verfechter jedenfalls in
der rhetorik eines radikalen einer eines
radikalen neubeginn es ist ja donald
trump der vor vier jahren die wahl
gewonnen hat in dem er gesagt hat ja
das wort den sumpf trockenlegen neu
beginnen deckt mit den ganzen alten
politikern also leute die beiden sagt er
immer noch
beiden war ja die ganze zeit in der
politik das ist kontinuität das wollen
wir nicht sondern wir beginnen ganz fern
und das ist auch bei trun also
wahrscheinlich nicht bewusst aber in
seinem umfeld verbunden mit einer
eigentlich konsistenten politischen
theorie kramp selbst also seine
persönlichkeit also man darüber denken
wie man will aber als phänomen ist das
schon wichtig und diese die rhetorik der
diskontinuität bei ihm ist etwas was man
berücksichtigen muss oder kann oder
sollte okay also gerade auch in dem in
dem zusammenhang
wir machen hier philosophie nicht
politische theorie und der die differenz
ist dass die philosophie nicht bestrebt
ist antworten zu finden also die
philosophie ist nicht dazu gedacht
antworten zu finden die philosophie
aufgabe der philosophie ist fragen zu
formulieren
also das ist so quasi das sokratische
motiv der sokratische ist das des fragen
und das ermöglichen
davon dass gedanken zustande kommen
die fehler in philosophische die
politische philosophie hat nicht die
aufgabe jetzt gross auf zu treten und
sagen so jetzt werden sind wir marxisten
oder jetzt sind wir
roxana oder karl schmidt oder sonstwas
sondern es ist die philosophie ist dazu
da die fragen zu stellen und die fragen
in der philosophie sind letztendlich die
in der politischen philosophie sind dies
die gleichen fragen wie sonst überall in
der philosophie nämlich letztendlich die
metaphysischen fragen
es ist wichtig das zu berücksichtigen
in der metaphysik gibt es keine
endgültigen antworten
es gibt immer nur eine auswahl
vielleicht mal so oder mal so
das ist der grund warum in der
philosophie und insbesondere in der
metaphysik die methode dialektik heißt
die meter die metaphysik erarbeitet sich
ihre stoffe mit auf dialektische art und
weise das heißt sie erfasst gegensätze
und die fragen die sich stellt schweben
sozusagen zwischen den gegensätzen
wir sind keine antworten sondern es sind
formulierte fragen und die fragen die in
der politischen philosophie hochkommen
sind auch analog das heißt es gibt
richtungen denkrichtungen denkmuster die
als ich aus der metaphysik speisen und
die keine eindeutige antwort vorgeben
also das was quasi die positiven
wissenschaften wie auch die politische
theorie auszeichnet im gegensatz zur
philosophie ist dass die positive
wissenschaften sind eine positive
wissenschaft braucht ergebnisse die fans
aufgebraucht keine ergebnisse wir auch
keine ergebnisse haben das ist nicht
ihre rolle das heißt nicht dass der
philosoph oder die philosophin sich
quasi
elfenbeinturm sich jeder meinung enthält
das ganz und gar nicht aber die
disziplin die den meinungen der
philosophieren
zugrunde liegt ist dialektisch
jedenfalls der dialektik bin ich dann
doch ein fehler für trump oder vermeiden
aber bevor ich so weit komme als
philosoph bin ich dialektiker okay
übrigens apropos diese zum geschichte
sie können natürlich sich melden und so
viel ich war es und ich habe auch nichts
dagegen wenn sie das tun
sofern ich das jetzt technisch
bewältigen kann aber auf alle fälle ok
da sind ein paar chat bemerkungen das
ist sehr dass ich sehr leise den ist das
richtig gehören sie mich ich weiß
allerdings nicht genau wie ich das
einstellen falls sie mich nicht hören
naja wenn sie mich nicht hören ja ja gut
ein bisschen leise kann man das mikrofon
irgendwie
okay gut danke für die information
ich werde weiterhin laut sprechen ich
bin ja auch in einem riesigen hörsaal
okay gut also jetzt noch einmal ganz
kurz
wir werden dann im laufe der vorlesung
immer wieder auf metaphysische fragen
zurückkommen aber die frage hier
wie gesagt habe ich vorher angesteckt
ist die frage der kontinuität und die
frage der kontinuität ist eine
klassische frage der erkenntnistheorie
die erkenntnistheorie stellt sich die
frage oder unter anderem was ist
veränderung und klassik platten esstisch
sozusagen erfasst die erkenntnis nur
statische gegebenheiten
also das ist sozusagen das öl in höhlen
gleichen ist von platon das was quasi
hinter dem flackernden erscheinungen es
ist etwas festes ist existiert permanent
und für immer und die antwort oder wie
man wie soll man sich das vorstellen
klassischerweise auch bei platon ist der
gedanke ja das ist wie die mathematik
oder vor allem vor die die die
arithmetik also arithmetik hat ein
festes gefüge von beständigen größe
das ist etwas was man im eigenen kopf
bearbeiten kann aber wunder aller wunder
ist es auch etwas was sich auf die
realität anwenden lässt
also das ist dass das spannende an der
arithmetik
das wird vielleicht noch einläuft und
damit den komplizierteren
ebenen der modernen mathematik wo der
normale mensch sich überhaupt nicht
vorstellen kann dass das irgendwas mit
der realität zu tun hätte aber trotzdem
scheinbar offensichtlich hat etwas mit
der realität zu tun und diese das war in
der in der philosophie philosophie der
antike hat man das vor allem an der
astronomie festgebunden
in der astronomie kann man man man sieht
wie die himmelskörper einen beständigen
reigen vollziehen und es wiederholt sich
und es ist fest und es ist ewig und und
immer da und es lässt sich mathematisch
beschreiben teilweise ebenfalls in der
antike und das ist dann ein bild dafür
die tatsächlich das was eigentlich nur
im gedanken zunächst mal nur in den
gedanken im hirn ist sich ohne
unterbrechung auf das auch die reale
welt übertragen lässt
ok also das ist so quasi der der anfang
aber der nächste schritt ist ja wie
mache ich was mache ich dann mit
veränderung weil die festen größen der
arithmetik sind zunächst mal nicht
unbedingt lassen sich nicht so gut
vereine verbinden mit dem gedanken der
veränderung was ist jetzt die
veränderung und damit haben sich die
antiken philosophen auch an
auseinandergesetzt
vor allem mit den paradoxien der
bewegungen bei 10 an
in aristoteles physik beispielsweise ist
eine diskussion von diesem paradoxien
die paradoxie ist wie soll man das jetzt
verstehen dass ein pfeil sich bewegt
also ein pfeil stellt man sich vor als
etwas festes
in der luft es liegt aber es ist in der
luft und so quasi mathematisch
analytisch kann ich mir das noch
vorstellen das ist einfach daher ist die
wahrheit ist der fall ist da aber
trotzdem bewegt dass ich wie kann das
sein
das empfanden die antiken philosophen
als als paradox und als nachweis je
nachdem was was es dass es beweisen
sollte aber ebenfalls dass die reine
platonische lehre hier
überzeugungsarbeit leisten müsste okay
das ist jetzt meine für uns heutzutage
ist das ist das vielleicht nicht mehr so
ohne weiteres nachvollziehbar aber wie
sie wissen in der neuzeit hat die die
mathematik auch oder ende der großen
errungenschaften der der neuzeitlichen
mathematik ist die fähigkeit mit
veränderung und bewegung fertig zu
werden nämlich in der internet- des iman
rechnung von leibnitz beziehungsweise
von youtube
ok also das sind kern paradoxien
vielleicht oder oder rätsel ist die welt
jetzt besteht die die die welt aus
sorry ich muss los geht das nicht
automatisch
naja ok besteht oder ist die wahrheit
etwas was nur fest und und wandelbar ist
es dass das ist die eine möglichkeit die
andere möglichkeit ist es die wahrheit
mit festen unwahr und wandelbaren
ereignissen gar nichts zu tun hat
sondern ständig im fluss ist das sind
zwei denkbare möglichkeiten und es sind
möglichkeiten die dann bis in die tiefen
der metaphysik einschließen und
leitbilder bereitstellen
für auseinandergehende weltanschauliche
komponenten also beispielsweise der
moderne empirismus also ab naja so
modern ist das nicht aber abgesagt
fundamental sind nicht die festen
gegebenheiten von platon sondern es ist
die bewegung und die das erfassen wir
mit der sinnlichkeit also die sinne das
sind das fundieren und die sinne sind
ständig in bewegung also was ich jetzt
wahr nehme jetzt ist im fluss
es ist nichts festes ich kann daraus
entnehmen dass es feste gegebenheiten
dahinter gibt aber zunächst mal ist
alles im fluss und das ist die wahrheit
ebene nicht die platonische ebene und
das wiederum für borkum war ein nachweis
dafür dass der römische bischof der
papst keine ansprüche hat oder nur
geminderter ansprüche weltlicher
ansprüche gegen de bei den weltlichen
herrschern wie in franken vor dem
bayerischen prinzen ja okay also das
sind sprünge aber die metaphysik fließt
in solche bahnen hinein und je nachdem
was man sich weltalls als leitmotiv
seines denkens das liest auch hinein in
die politischen einstellung der gedanke
der wipfel der wandelbarkeit der
kontinuität
es spielt auch in der theologie eine
wichtige rolle also bei auch kommt
gewissermaßen auch aber in der neueren
theologie beispielsweise bei jürgen
kehrer dort hat hegel kritisiert weil er
meinte hegel würde alles reduzieren auf
so einer mechanik die ganze welt besteht
aus einer mechanik und
diese maschine wird erscheinungen auf
und es ist mehr oder weniger alles
vorgegeben und ein unendliches conti
norden und das sagt kirche code
entspricht überhaupt nicht der wahrheit
und erst recht nicht der wahrheit der
christlichen religion
weil für die künstliche religion sagt
kickl gott die christliche religion
gegründet auf diskontinuität was ist
jesus jesus ist die absolute
diskontinuität der es besteht überhaupt
keine notwendigkeit dass jesus kommen
sollte und wenn er kommt dann ist das
mit schrecken und und beleidigungen und
beschimpfungen verbunden also hier ist
kein siegel ist es so dass das die
geschichte der der geist der geschichte
dafür sorgt dass alles schön regelmäßig
sich aufbaut und am ende hat man den
preußischen staat und das ist das ende
der geschichte und zweiteres okay also
das ist hegel kirche gott sagt nein mit
nicht denn die des weges und der
geschichte ist die diskontinuität es
kommt einfach ein moment wo plötzlich
die alte geschichte aufhört und dass
neues beginnt und sein bild dafür oder
mehr als bild das ist das was er
erklären ist jesus also jesus ist
einfach das schlechthin neue der punkt
wo die alte geschichte aufhören ok also
dass das ist ist sind zu diesem
metaphysischen richtungen
die im bestimmten positiven bereichen
erkennbar werden oder angewandt werden
aber letztendlich in ganz tiefen
metaphysischen entscheidungen wurzeln ja
okay also der gedanke gegart und darüber
werden die ein bisschen mehr zu sagen
haben später dieser gedanke dass oder
kickern formuliert dass mit dem begriff
des augenblicks augenblick also auf den
es ist es fast dasselbe wort im
augenblick verändert sich der wandel
augenblick ist das wo keine zeit ist
aber wo die neue zeit plötzlich
einbricht
ein augenblick ist etwas außerhalb der
zeit ist das ist ein begriff auch aus
diesem antiken paradoxien augenblick
also der der pfeil hängt in der luft in
einem augenblick und ist nicht in der
zeit und bewegt sich nicht
zenon jedenfalls und das ist das
mysteriöse wie kann wie kann ein fall
dass sich nicht bewegt dann doch sich
bewegen und sich dann woanders befinden
also natürlich tut es dass die frage ist
was ist die wahrheit davon oder wie
können wir das jetzt gedanklich
begrifflich erfassen gut für kinder
gehört ebenfalls erholt diese dieser
alte vorstellung hervor aus der aus der
geschichte der philosophie für ihn ist
ist ein augenblick auch der punkt wo das
neue kommt ohne notwendigkeit völlig
frei etwas absolut unvorhergesehenes so
und jetzt sind wir bei schmidt war
schmidt ist biografisch sie können sich
sicherlich ausbilden oder die leicht
ausbauen schnittger schmidt war ein nazi
ist der nazi partei beigetreten 1933 und
blieb bei denen auch bis 45 und er hat
auch
berechtigterweise tore ist schriften
verfasst die die nazis auch unterstützt
haben er war ein hochbegabter philosoph
und politischer denker aber er hat
beispielsweise auch die nacht der langen
messer hier in tegernsee wo hitler seine
seine gegner ausgeschaltet hat so
einfach hingegangen hat sie dann
erschossen und umgebracht
ohne verfahren ohne prozess um alles
das hat karl schmidt gerichtet ist hat
gesagt ja das steht dem führer zu das
ist auch okay dass er das macht das ist
das ist im sinne in seinem sinne
da hat er gesagt auch rechtmäßig
ja okay gut also das ist die negative
seite auf der anderen seite das positive
beispiel ist dass er ein begnadeter
stilist ist immer noch gerne gelesen
wird
also ich ließ ihn auch gerne aber
natürlich mit großer innerlicher distanz
zu seinen politischen ein sicherer
überhaupt zu sagen einzigen wie wir
sehen dann aber jedenfalls ein sehr
doppeldeutig charakter auch einer
übrigens der karl der von walter
benjamin gerne gelesen wurde der
natürlich politisch auch der völlig
gegensätzlich inside steht gut also
jetzt calw mit
warum karl schmidt karl schmidt ist ein
existenzialist existenzialist das ist
die thematik die auch bargeld abhebt
existenz ist primär gegenüber essence
existenz heißt wie man so gerade da ist
bei heidegger heißt es da sein
also es ist nicht das wesen ist das
wesentliche nicht so platonische
abstraktionen nicht feste gegebenheiten
sondern existenz und existenz ist
wandelbar existenz ist das was dem
entstehen und vergehen unterworfen ist
und schmidt sagt grundlage stellt sich
die frage was es jetzt politik und seine
antwort ist politik ist das was als
existenzfrage oder oder als als als
existenz eines volkes entsteht also die
gedanken der gedanke könnte sein
politik ist ist die art und weise wie
man mit verwaltungsaufgaben innerhalb
eines staates umgeht oder wie man dafür
sorgt dass das die leute angemessen
vertreten werden oder was auch immer
nein sagt karl schmidt es ist sie
wichtiger als das politik ist viel
wichtiger als das politik ist in der
politik geht es um existenz und diese
existenz ist etwas das mit irgendwelchen
überzeitlichen oder über nationalen
gegebenheiten mit denen hat es überhaupt
nichts zu tun also existenz ist die
unmittelbare physische gegebenheit einer
gruppe von menschen und diese gruppe von
menschen also es bietet sich zunächst
mal an wäre unter anderem das volk ja
das volk ist halt da dass dieses dasein
des volkes ist ist seine existenz und
von dieser existenz fließt alles andere
und das ist dann die frage was wie
verstehe ich diese existenz
das ist jetzt theoretisch ausgangspunkt
der unmittelbare anlass für schmitt und
das darf man nicht vergessen
das war für die 20er jahre insgesamt
bezeichnen also es gibt zwei elemente
wie wir wissen mit den zwei wochen da
die hand in den 20er jahren
das eine war der der erste weltkrieg das
ende des weltkrieges und dann gerade in
deutschland die folgen aus dem
versailler friedensvertrag aus dem
wasser friedensvertrag sind diese sehr
schwerwiegenden reparationen die
zahlungen die deutschland verlegt wurden
und die sehr schwerwiegende
wirtschaftliche folgen hat für
deutschland unter anderem und
deutschland müsse seine ganzen kolonien
abgeben und lauter demütig in der
entwürdigende folgen aus dem ersten
krieg also das ist das eine das ist ganz
deutlich bei schnitt zu spüren nach
übrigens jetzt noch den hintergrund zu
erklären in diesen vorlesungen mach ich
immer auszüge aus den texten die ich für
wichtig halte und das habe ich auch
jetzt hier schnitt gemacht
aus meiner auszüge aus mit text begriff
des politischen finden sie auf der
webseite und können sie herunterladen
ich tue das um mir selber zu helfen aber
auch um um ihnen ich würde auch sagen
also falls sie jetzt eine
prüfungsleistung abgeben wollen
ich würde sei es okay meine persönliche
empfehlung aber so arbeite ich seit
vielen jahren in sivas schreiben dann
machen sie doch bitte auch eine
zitatensammlung zuerst das hilft die
organisation des schreibens zum einen
zum anderen ist das auch sind das auch
ihre beweismaterialien wenn sie etwas
behaupten über beispiel über jetzt
elfmeter das 1
brauchen sie zitate originalton caf mit
das ist dass das ist das richtige damit
sie dann belege haben dafür was was
gesagt werden soll
übrigens ich ja da haben wir auch noch
die andere meta meta bemerkung falls sie
jetzt eine hausarbeit zu diesem oder
überhaupt zu philosophischen themen
erarbeiten bitte haben sie verständnis
dafür ihre eigene meinung interessiert
nicht das ist nicht ihre aufgabe als
silos das hängt zu sagen mit dem was ich
am anfang gesagt habe es ist es ist
sie dürfen gerne in der meinung haben
das freut mich dass eine meinung haben
aber die das was sie schreiben erstellen
da geht es nicht um ihre meinung sondern
es geht um die klare darstellung dessen
was oder einer position nicht unbedingt
das was einer gesagt hat aber einer
position und das möglichst dialektisch
mit dem sinne dass sie sagen es gibt
diese möglichkeit und dann gibt es die
andere möglichkeit ok genug damit
ich würde allerdings noch eine bemerkung
machen zu es gibt moderne ausgaben von
also der begriff des
das politische ist eine sehr bekannte
schrift und ist auch berühmt berüchtigt
und wird oft zitiert als als beleg dafür
was sie ein schrecklicher nazi schmidt
war also bitte vergessen sie dass das
ist jetzt nicht der punkt
es ist sehr verwurzelt in seiner zeit
das ist richtig und schmidt hat die
nazis unterstützt ok geschenkt aber das
ist jetzt nicht der unmittelbare punkt
als wichtig wäre ist dass die ausgabe
die man heute in den läden kaufen kann
ist eine ausgabe aus 1963 und es ist
schon ein bisschen von schmidt selbst
saniert worden interessanter sind die
ursprünglichen ausgaben also dass dieses
pamphlet oder dieser aussage ist zuerst
in einer zeitschrift erschienen 1927 und
dann in buchform sechs jahre später
fünf jahre später und es heißt zwar in
der 63er ausgabe das ist einfach die 32
ausgabe nur keine ahnung bis hin
mit ein paar weiteren fußnoten versehen
oder irgendwas stimmt nicht wenn sie die
ursprüngliche ausgabe lesen würden dann
ergibt sich einiges mehr ist das aus dem
neuen okay das kriegen sie auch im
internet allerdings bis oder in den
bibliotheken auch gut jetzt übrigens ich
lese meistens nicht viel mehr als 50
minuten
das heißt ich werde schon darauf hören
so jetzt der begriff des politischen bei
der hintergrund ist seine
auseinandersetzung mit dem liberalismus
und das ist so ein bisschen natürlich
verdeckt
die bösen engländer jetzt in den
nachgang zum ersten weltkrieg die bösen
engländer oder vielleicht noch mehr die
amerikaner vertreten den liberalismus
was ist jetzt liberalismus wie schon
gesagt liberalismus denken von den
denkern hier aber das wird von ihnen
nicht erwähnt ist adams mit gewinn er
erwähnt ist etwas berg ist vielleicht
wichtiger für diese geschichte
aber der gedanke bei adam smith wie sie
wahrscheinlich wissen
der gedanke warum ist dass die das wesen
der menschlichen organisation und daher
auch des staates ist das eigeninteresse
also ein eigeninteresse das
eigeninteresse ist der motor der
menschlichen existenz für smes die
einzelnen individuen konkurrieren
miteinander im wirtschaftlichen und
durch diese konkurrenz entsteht eine
dynamik aus der der moderne staat
entstehen kann und wenn man diese call
dieser konkurrenz freien lauf lässt dann
hat man alles was man so braucht in form
von humanität und moral und auch
schönheit usw
allerdings müsse wie es ein zeitgenosse
und und freund david hume sehen ihn
quasi in den natürlichen veranlagungen
des menschen in der angeborenen
sensibilität des menschen
die grundlage für all das was wir gut
heißen auch gerade auch in der moral
als junges mädchen beide der meinung
wenn man den menschen ist eine eigene
die verantwortung für die eigenen
handlungen überlässt dann werden sie
auch also wenn nicht unbedingt lieb
zueinander sein
falls rational und tolerant und
kooperativ sein das ist dieses das
positive angeblich an diesem
liberalismus oder oder individualismus
es ist eine im wesentlichen positive
einstellung der welt gegenüber gut was
ist jetzt mit mit den 20er jahren und
uns mit wir hatten zuerst habe ich schon
erwähnt dem ersten weltkrieg
und da im hintergrund so eine gewisse
angespannte distanz zu der ideologie der
siegermächte das ist eine das andere was
wir natürlich in den 20er jahren haben
ist ein ganz heftiger blutiger
bürgerkrieg in russland der nach der
revolution ausgebrochen ist 1917
oktoberrevolution in russland gefolgt
von einem langwierigen und sehr
grausamen bürgerkrieg und diese beiden
elemente diese beiden einbrüche in der
geschichte bilden den hintergrund für
das was schmidt sich jetzt überlebt ok
schmitz ausgangspunkt ist dann wie
gesagt der gedanke gibt was ist in der
im menschlichen leben existenz was ist
das grundlegend existenzielle war das
existenzielle die körperlichkeit also
dass ich sterbe dass ich leide das ist
die unmittelbare existenz existenz und
daraus ich meine das ist viel wichtiger
als alle systematischen glaubens oder
der gedanke an
eine weltkirche die sich dann in der
entwickelt und so weiter also clique gab
gegenüber der katholischen kirche noch
viel es gibt es gegenüber riegel also
dass dass der gedanke aber das wird dann
übertragen weil schmidt auf den gedanken
ja was ist jetzt das worauf es wirklich
ankommt
bei den menschen nämlich das
existenzielle sein begriff und das
existenzielle für schmidt ist die
gemeinschaft die kämpft es ist die
kämpfende gemeinschaft eine gesamtheit
von menschen sagt er
die kämpft die kämpfende gesamtheit okay
also das ist wie gesagt auch dem
hintergrund der damaligen geschichte ein
bisschen verständlich aber was sollte
was soll jetzt daraus werden
der unmittelbare anlass also der
begrifflicher anlass für schmied ist ein
buch von wladimir litwin und das buch
heißt staat und revolution und im staat
und revolution das 1917 erschienen ist
im vorfeld der rolle der russischen
revolution wie sie wissen oder weiß ich
ob sie es wissen aber linien war auch
wie ich mit auch in münchen teilweise
jedenfalls linie war zu fuß oder während
des krieges in der schweiz und die
deutsche die deutschen haben linien 1917
in einem geschlossenen
eisenbahnwaggon nach russland
verfrachtet um dort sein unwesen zu
treiben also das ist ganz interessant
also die die die macht der ideologie und
es war dass es war der deutsche
regierung klar also wenn wir mit diesem
mann nach deutschland nach russland
bringen dann wird er dort unruhe stiften
und das wird für uns kann für uns nur
vorteilhaft seiner das willst dann
erfolgt schmidt lehnt nachdem er staat
und revolution eröffnet vollendet
publiziert hat 1917 ist dann fuhr dann
nach leningrad und kurz danach ist die
revolution ausgebrochen
okay das war jetzt nur als fußnote aber
der gedanke bye lenin ist was ist
revolution lenin kritisiert die er sagt
die erste bürgerliche marxisten weil die
bürgerlichen marxisten denken na ja gut
also wir können den staat so reformen
reformieren dass er etwas humaner wird
dass die das proletariat nicht so eine
bedrückte existenz führt weiter das
ginge vielleicht leni sagt nein ist
ausgeschlossen
der start in dieser form der staat ist
nur ein produkt der bourgeoisie um das
polit arena zu unterdrücken
es ist eine waffe im klassenkampf und er
sagt grund die grundlage ist oder die
die grundlage überhaupt für die
politische entwicklung spricht hierfür
die revolution ist dass man das erkennt
er sagt der staat ist das produkt und
die äußerung der unversöhnlichkeit der
klassengegensätze ja
also das ist das entscheidende wort
hierfür lehnen die unversöhnlichkeit der
klassengegensätze der staat entsteht
dort dann und insofern wo wann und
inwiefern die klassengegensätze objektiv
nicht versöhnt werden können
ok also das ist dann konflikt ein
konflikt den mann nicht überbrücken kann
es ist nicht wie die bürgerliche
marxisten gedacht hatten dass wir da
irgendwelche reformen durchführen kann
und den start dann also in einem
sozialstaat verwandeln oder sonstwas wie
bismarck es ja versucht hatte nein sagt
linie das geht nicht die
klassengegensätze sind absolut und die
einzige antwort hier ist revolution und
revolution heißt gewalt
das ist das entscheidende bei linien und
das ist es dann auch gefolgt und ist
dann in einen bürgerkrieg übergegangen
das war quasi also jenes halt das was
linien schon im staat und revolution
propagiert hatte das wird dann
übernommen
von karl schmidt aber ein bisschen
anders formuliert aber der gedanke ist
er gleich bei carl schmitt geht es um
diese unversöhnlichen gegensätze
für karl schmidt ist bestimmend für die
identität eines volkes oder für
politisches leben oder zusammenleben
oder sonstwas unpersönliches
unversöhnlicher gegensatz zu anderen ja
also bei linien ist das proletariat und
wo ich was sie bei schmidt der lässt das
weg bei schnitt ist es mein volk und das
andere volk und daraus sagt er immer
wieder aber jetzt hinter simon in der
früheren ausgabe das ist etwas was man
in der späteren ausgabe in der
deutlichkeit nicht findet schmidt sagt
ja okay und das führt zu einem
bürgerkrieg
und das ist gut so sagt man nicht
eindeutig aber die die konsequenz ist
eines denkens ist erstens existenzielle
existenzieller konflikt weil nur in
diesem konflikt nur sagt er im ernstfall
entsteht ein verständnis für meine
existenz nicht meine private persönliche
das ist individualismus
aber wenn eine gesamtheit eines volkes
in konflikt gerät mit einem anderen volk
dann ist das der ernstfall dann geht da
nichts mehr dann geht nur existenz meine
existenz gegen seine existenz deren
existenz und das ist die
unversöhnlichkeit die schon lenin
propagiert hatte das ist der auslöser
der revolution auslösen auch des
bürgerkriegs und das ist gut das ist gut
so wie lenin und dann schmidt das
verstehen ist das etwas gutes
nur über diesen bürgerkrieg kommen wir
zu einem verständnis dessen was wir
überhaupt sind das ist die politische
identität politische identität erwächst
aus dem konflikt ja das kann schon krieg
seien
das ist etwas was karl schmidt quasi
dahin stellt das kann schon krieg seien
aber wirklich was was in den in der
früheren ausgabe ist das ganz klar dass
eigentlich paradigmatisch für diese
entwicklung ist nicht irgendein krieg
mit irgendeinem benachbarten einer
benachbarten nationen sondern
klassenkampf beziehungsweise für karl
schmidt bürgerkrieg zwischen den völkern
ja wenn ein volk oder innerhalb eines
volkes oder im rahmen eines volkes diese
konflikte ausbrechen dann entsteht die
identität die existenzielle identität
die wir suchen die wir brauchen alles
menschen ja okay also das ist ein
bisschen klingt ein bisschen negativ und
hat mir alles ein bisschen negativ
irgendwann wenn sie es ist ich habe es
auf meinen experten
vermerkt wenn sie diese 32er ausgabe im
internet runterladen das ist bei einer
amerikanischen bibliothek und ich bin
fast sicher dass dieses exemplar das die
da haben aus den beständen von hannah
arendt kommt und ich meine wenn es
hannah arendt ist aber auch egal weil es
sind interessante notizen in dieser
ausgearbeiteten handschriftliche notizen
und es lohnt sich sich die anzugucken
aber okay dass das nur nebenbei so jetzt
ich will jetzt sie nicht abschrecken
also karl schmidt ist wichtig und
interessant
das klingt zwar schockierend was ich
jetzt gerade in seinem sinne vorgetragen
hat und es ist auch schockierend aber
trotzdem der text ist interessant und
das sind auch wirklich interessante
punkte dabei und es ist nicht so dass er
in barbarischer inhumanität propagiert
ja jetzt müssen wir alle übereinander
herfallen und uns töten
das ist drin aber das ist quasi nicht
der anlass der anlass ist wirklich
gewissermaßen ein humana meine unter
anderem sagt das macht auch sinn
der gedanke dass die menschen bereit
sein sollten zu sterben nur um
wirtschaftliche vorteile zu gewinnen das
ist das ist barbarisch sagt ich denke
das ist auch richtig
ich meine ob das jetzt eine
entschuldigung ist ist eine andere frage
aber gut so weit jetzt erst mal als als
einstieg in schmidt wir zu ihm möchte
ich nächste woche und auch ein bisschen
was sagen und dann und dann gehen wir
weiter mit den anderen themen
ok jetzt ich glaube sie können sich
schon melden
und wenn sie fragen haben
naja ok